[Music]
in masturbation training news oh we
heard about the radio ads money
submitted by Genesis Tyson Fury says
he's masturbating seven times a day to
prepare for the Deontay Wilder rematch I
heard that he said he's gonna continue
to masturbate seven times at night he's
gonna start
what's the methodology behind this if I
jerk off sometimes day it gives me what
more testosterone he's like trying to
keep his testosterone levels like really
high or he gets so horny when he's
inside the ring he's I got to make sure
I keep it down masturbating seven times
a day seven times to keep my
testosterone pumping pumping pumping
pumping and then you started singing
them pump it up no no no I'm sold
endures does it need to go see someone
talk about therapists probably just the
way he's talking this sounds crazy
yeah guys were talking about Tyson Fury
Deontay Wilder
so Tyson's the white guy yeah he's the
jerk okay yeah he's a jerk okay this is
our second fight people say that Tyson
Fury had Deonte in points but then
Deontay Wilder it's like this was like
the knockout of the century she's gonna
go boom max Tyson through to the ground
and he starts cheering and they thought
you knocked him out the nose I ten nine
eight and this guy miraculously gets
back up and you even see John tailwater
like what the [ __ ]
and Deontay Wilder is like a knockout
artist I think he's had 40-something
fights and 40 of them are knockouts holy
so I was like the next is the next
coming of Mike Tyson everyone think
she's nice kind of might ties he puts
people out this guy he he only his first
year of boxing he went to the Olympics
they got a bronze medal Wow he's just a
phenom I get it yeah so this is the
second fight it's highly highly here so
he knocked him on the ground and then
this guy gets up and he's like he's like
I jerked off
I don't think you know what you're
dealing with um like I'd be after so
times seven times this is a lot that's a
lot
Wow [ __ ] time what's okay what's a lot
before you hitting said like it's three
a lot Leary's a lot maybe more than what
is a lot more regular the ones a lot I'm
here would you do regular [ __ ]
and like let's say you have a
nine-to-five yeah you have a job like
other responsibilities jackoff before
you go to work right you go to work you
come home and kind of tired I don't
think you're in the mood or yeah okay
cool I'll go to work I come on my
jackoff you play with the kids and then
you go jack off again spitting two and
three it's a lot you can't get there you
can't give you the number schedule oh
yeah he's like full-on he's like working
with his trainer so seven times every
single day seems like and not just that
but then he's saying that he's been
doing a lot of things he didn't do
before including eating five or six
meals a day and drinking eight liters of
water what did he eat it can you imagine
like Jack now with every every meal it's
not okay Jack's off take the nap drinks
the [ __ ] in her water goes to the
bathroom Jack's off again eats again
like well that's yeah I think cuz you
have to sleep after you jack off right
so it's like all [ __ ] okay wait how long
is the cooldown period after you come
hold on that's cute as you cook Julia
after after after you come like can't
come again right after it depends on the
depends are all warning yeah all depends
if I'm super [ __ ] horny I can just
keep going oh and Jack off I mean income
yeah multiple times usually gotta wait
like I can't do that yet I gotta wait
like an hour same hour I got Joe right
away no I think I've been there it's
just effing I'm super [ __ ] horny yeah
and it's been like you've got to tell it
my friend six seven eight times in a row
I just pictured this scary movie scene
orient like busting nuts
yeah dude he's busted intent and it's
coming out of [ __ ] nose I want to
watch a documentary on this guy's
training like and then eat and then how
he fits the element that yeah how does
he fit all of that into a schedule
hanging out with his kids
I think yeah I think so oh I think he's
uh I think something's wrong with him
then would be bad hyper sexual I think
he is legitimately after that
testosterone [ __ ] so that if you're not
horny you can make yourself morning cuz
I know for me if I'm not horny it
doesn't matter what I'm doing like
[ __ ] I better not use Jesus but some
miracle needs to happen and then I'm
like oh yeah okay cool no guys are a
little bit so Jesus can help you turn
get turned on yeah I think guys guys can
get activated much quicker yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think guys if they're
bored they can go no jack off when
they're bored right like it's not like a
go-to boy but for guys it'd be like I
think Nicky does I think Nicky jerks off
when she's born okay
in oh now I think I think she has I
don't know I don't know
oh I remember doing she like that in
high school
discover that the cars in the my god
yeah anyway happy Honda days when is
this fight you guys are watching it I
don't know what it is actually I dunno
I'm gonna order it then Dan this poor I
feel bad for his dick the whole sex
orgasm testosterone thing that's
actually what the Germans were doing
back in the day for the Olympics really
uh they had the female swim team they
would have liked sports massagers come
in oh and then all rub all their klitz
so that they can perform better and swim
faster you for the girls because even
girls get a testosterone spike
interesting and what's this last one
comes more muscle mass comes more
competitive drive I can't remember I saw
this or heard this I feel like it was in
a movie or something but like I've heard
that it's not good for a guy to have sex
before like a major sporting event yeah
I heard that before too but that's more
of like like the old trainer like mr.
Miyagi like that kind of myth I think
now the the comment like now with actual
medicine and stats and stuff what
they've shown is people that are more
sexually active regardless if you're
jacking off order for having sex you're
just gonna have higher testosterone
levels because you know if you don't use
it you lose it so if you are not having
sex at all even though you're training
an ass off in the in in like the box in
boxing gyms or wherever your
testosterone will start to dip no matter
what why are we gonna listen to him no
[ __ ]
what I thought about what he just said
he was such a clown thing I know not a
beauty guru thing no something about
Fitness I know I should have asked a
funny guy yeah I mean but here I was
gonna clown it was a complete clown yeah
it's cuz every video he refuses to admit
that he's like knows a lot about fitness
aka a fitness guru Brandie literally Oh
a lot but I'm not a guru you have a
[ __ ] business that sells programs and
to people that teaches them movement
barbell barbell them doing a lot of
[ __ ] around you
Oh what you're smiling while you're
working out so all the clients oh you're
misleading everyone you just casually
gained all that mass okay you're like
hey I'm real goofball today I word where
I put my pre workouts on top of my head
as I'm walking him out he literally does
that I know he's like I'm such a clown
why does anyone take me seriously talk
about tattoos dude 90% of the image is
workout 10% of the images goofs and he's
like I'm a goof off so hard and [ __ ]
testosterone in Germany and this and
madness that's you know back in the day
that's mr. Miyagi and I don't know [ __ ]
though this is comfortable what the hell
yeah but it sports not your shoes it's
all about you [ __ ] shoes I'm wearing
shoes how much of your week right now is
dedicated to training for a marathon him
how much money he's paying for coaching
and like all the different [ __ ] is
involved in well cuz I'm such a goofball
hey hey Bart so how many hours can you
write this month and how many hours can
you work out and run this month cornered
it's good question
you're a fitness I'm so goofy I can't
even answer that what you're accustomed
it beat that answer oh [ __ ]
um a week or a day a week doesn't matter
cuz he's got me I got zero on the
writing scale on it when he trash that
so much okay we met what really meant
wonder okay so he works out three times
a week like barbell training that's at
least three hours so don't like an hour
do that and then running now yeah he's
running a lot I think about a minimum an
hour now yeah and that's every single so
five times a week he's working out well
I consider the running is I'm working
out go to the gym and run for an hour
and say that I worked out all this [ __ ]
all the fitness sheet that it's not
working now you just [ __ ] sell shoes
and clothes you stupid [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] cooked he's got no case
makes you know Q you run in shoes that
are broken in and not new shoes I've
seen like a lot of people do that and
it's like the worst mistake ever they
come out with bloody feet what you're so
cute I think in love misty oh I'll go
somewhere and show anonymous random
people who don't know you your Instagram
and be like who do you think if you had
to say who this guy is and they'll all
say he's funny he's a clown well scroll
your Instagram I'll give him five
minutes and the Blake what a clown see
he looks like he tells a good joke yeah
I like to [ __ ] around they have a good
time
[Music]
[Music]